[Musique]
lüke aux deux bourgs bonjour bonjour
alors l'uqo de boer vous avez 45 ans
vous êtes père veuf et père de trois
enfants vous êtes éleveurs bovins vous
êtes agriculteur et vous êtes membre
d'europe écologie les verts vous avez
l'investiture du parti et vous avez créé
le parti familial marinois et vous êtes
candidat donc aux marins qu'est ce qui
vous motive pourquoi vous aller à la
bataille des municipales aux marins bon
c'est pas que le marin je les fais en
métropole et pour moi c'est un rêve et
un c'est un défi et puis j'aime ma
commune j'ai rien contre les adversaires
mais c'est mon rêve que je vais réaliser
et puis aidé parce que j'ai les fins
metropol déjà mais j'ai jamais eu
l'opportunité darde est aussi prêt de ce
grade
même si ils ont un échec mais pour moi
ce serait une victoire parce que je
réalisais ce que je vais faire et mes
premiers supporters c'est mes enfants
parce que tout le monde m'ont dit n'y va
pas ils m'ont donné des critiques
les enfants ont dit papa je vais le
faire fait le pas ce que tu vas le
regretter
alors fait le sait ça vous êtes très
proche de vos enfants quand même on le
voit qu'est ce qui est fait le déclic
aujourd'hui parce que dagan vous l'aviez
déjà fait
en france dans l'hexagone dans quelle
commune
vous aviez à dinan d'accord à dinan le
maire qu'est la ci s'appelle monsieur le
chien qui est qui était premier adjoint
du prochain l'ancien maire qui était là
et maintenant qu'ils maire de dinan et
qui m'a bien formés en fait la compagnie
municipale les valides
envoyez-les réduit l'hydra les tracks me
faire confiance
un moment donné la parole il s'assoit
donner la parole hippie dieu voyez c
c'était une dynamique
kim a un qui m'a poussé et puis le fait
qu'on m'a fait confiance à main je pense
que aujourd'hui j'ai rien à perdre
personnellement mes adversaires - jeu
j'espère que ils vont pas s'entre tuent
entre eux mais moi je ne suis pas là
pour ça je suis pas là pour ça je les
dis bien que une politique qu'on fait
une campagne on sait pas on n'est pas là
pour se déchirer faut le respect se
déchirer à les développer la vie de
celui de ceux là ah ben c'est pas une
campagne pour lui il faut d'abord se
respecte et là c'est pas une poire se
respecte et de a jusqu'à z
parce qu'une autre jour de cette
tendance d'envoyer des piques je vous
donne un exemple j'ai fait toutes les
campagnes politiques
en métropole la dernière que j'ai fait
ça avec eux c'est à saint pierre avec
comme il s'appelle madame gustou qui se
présente comme contre monsieur la fin
banal quand j'étais avec la dernière
campagne que j'ai fait le tapis pas sûr
d'accord très bien alors c'est que c'est
quoi le parti familial parce que vous
avez créé le parti familial
expliquez-nous ce que c'est exactement
baisse à un parti qui ne rejette
personne est là pour tout comme disait
coluche je prends tous les rejeter
ouais je veux je pense je ne mets pas
d'étiquette ou qui que ce soit mais
aujourd'hui on va dire bon celui-là il
est où mon nom j'ai fait tout le monde
tout le monde sait ça un parti familial
voilà vous avez vous avez un programme
et dans les grandes lignes de votre
programme il y à la lutte contre la
délinquance en faisant croit par exemple
en faisant quoi à bas ces jeunes là il
faudrait les faire confiance
ce que j'aime pas avec certains élus dès
qu'il y voilà abbey met une étiquette
pour eux ils vont demander quelque chose
on voit pas les données parce que j'ai
des locks tu as fait une connerie
il ya trop de préjugés ouais trop
diffuse et voilà mais pas content et en
un qui qu'ils ont pas de look so pas de
prix fusées ils sont là mais c'est le
plus mauvais alors parce que quand tu
vois les jeunes y sont au bord de la
route la sphère le conneries fumer faire
tout ce qu'il veut c'est pas le mec qui
a les locks qui emmène pour eux c'est un
gros bras car sa voiture qu'à un bon
poste et c'est lui qui tu détruis qui
détient enfants faisant faisant quoi par
exemple comme comme ce type d'action
avec ces jeunes là ces jeunes là ils
méritent quand je suis dans ma commune
aux marins il ya beaucoup de jeunes qui
aiment la pêche qui aime la pêche qu'ils
ont pas les moyens d'aller à trinité de
revenir ça à trinité l'école de pêche et
de la pêche
mais il ya beaucoup de jeunes dans ma
commune qui aiment ça et avant ces
jeunes là il était là maintenant ils ont
une habitude à b vont tout le temps à la
pêche
parce que parce que oui parce qu'on les
a laissés tomber ils ont laissé tomber
leur développer des actions pour
permettre des actions de formation avec
ces jeunes pour leur permettre de
s'épanouir d'avoir enfin avoir un créer
une fois tu as ton diplôme tu peu avant
un crédit acheter ton bateau vivent ta
vie coin mais il cette porte là elle est
fermée parce que ils ont illuminé tic
sur le soul au visage
par contre quand je vois au jeu vaut
qu'un label a pu par des pêcheurs ils
ont des l'occident tout abeilles sont
pas rejetés par la mer parce que quoi
pas vu travailler tu travailles il nous
reste plus de temps monsieur de vaud
merci beaucoup
bonne journée à l écoute de nos
programmes est ainsi monsieur ou debout
mais je vous remercie beaucoup
et puis je dis je souhaite une bonne
campagne à tout le monde et que le
meilleur gagne mais je suis pas là pour
gagner
je fais ma rentrée politique merci
beaucoup monsieur de moi parce que c'est
un parti qui vient de débuter et c'est
un parti pour le futur merci beaucoup
bonne journée
[Musique]